it's one thing when I'm performing the
lines in a studio it's another thing
when you watch it materialized on screen
Dwayne Johnson not only lends his voice
as Maui in the upcoming Disney
blockbuster Moana the oceans straight-up
kooky dukes
he's also unleashing his singing chops
don't mess with Maui when he's on the
freeway The Rock got an assist in the
recording studio from Hamilton's
lin-manuel Miranda who's one of the
songwriters for the movie I just sort of
thought what would be like the most fun
thing to hear the rock sing and it's
you're welcome
Maui's very determined I've been known
to be very determined Maui's incredibly
charismatic I got a little bit of that
Maui is I mean just between us he's
incredibly good-looking alright I got a
little bit of that Dwayne has such
incredible charm um and he's such a
humble guy even though he has no need to
be modest about anything the biggest
reason I wanted to be a part of the
movie was it was the opportunity to
showcase a culture that's very important
to me was the opportunity to showcase my
culture my hope what people in the world
will take away from watching Moana is
not only a better understanding of our
culture our tradition our pride our love
our joy our determination our mana our
spirit but also they will take away the
most important thing we all have family
you